[Musica]
titolo top fisse science houston
democrazia processo scientifico non è un
processo democratico e immagino che
molti di voi sa il nostro accento il
naso perché noi consigliamo democrazia
gli stand calici come teniamo
mutilazione questo concetto democratico
ma quali sono stato invitato deciso di
parlare di questa di questo argomento
perché ha avuto in prima persona modo di
discutere del fatto che sa i nostri
democrazia ma tentare questo episodio
che voi introdurre veramente la mia
ricerca
io lo studio questa classe di molecole
che sono nino titoli più fosfati e in
particolare delle influenze custode di
queste molecole bello che si chiama
anche ai mesi lo zucchero io sì d'oro
con sei gruppi fosfato attaccati e per
cui il nome inositolo se lo stato a
brindisi questa molecola il segno di
tutta i nostri cellule ma anche
particolarmente abbondanti nelle piane
al personamente a bollate nelle piante
infatti viene anche chiamato fini casini
in inglese o acido fitico e funziona
soprattutto nei seni prendendo nei
fagioli cento cambi fagioli contengono
da 5 a 10 grammi gli enti sic su questa
possibile che si è un prodotto naturale
che estrae a bassissimo costo delle
dalle piante quindi tutti ha generato ha
fatto
in questa triste hanno fatto sì che
l'industria tutto statunitense mente una
industria che mentre casey come
integratore alimentare e così il
giudizio né scrivere anche come una
panacea una fury diario per molte
malattie
quello che previene con un alzano i
calcoli renali abbassa il colesterolo
riduce il rischio di far tale promette
supera anche a curare il cancro
premesso questo due anni fa ho avuto il
piacere di collaborare con romeni varie
uno dei maggiori scienziati del mio
caldo di ricerca dell'università di
cambridge è insieme a roma abbiamo
sviluppato un nuovo metodo per l'analisi
delle di fix e con questo metodo sia
andato a vedere celebrities era presente
che in cui di umani nel nostro samp e
nemmeno suine e abbiamo scoperto che la
crisi e alla 7 a restituirgli umani
poiché gli scienziati alla fine di una
ricetta d'oro pubblicare i loro soldati
una rivista scientifica the con robbie
siamo riusciti a pubblicare questo su
questa rivista scientifica e la
conclusione del nostro la conclusione
del nostro del nostro
di questo che vanta di questo della
nostra ricerca
manco studiano che dato che nel sangue
del viso non viene non è presente
l'effetto benefico delle alpi sia stato
realmente da questa industria non può
essere manifestato dalle tesi non può
essere trasportato a sangue a lorca ma
un bersaglio quindi lo consigliamo il
gusto delle pizze come supplemento
alimentare naturalmente il giorno dopo
che questo lavoro è stato obbligato
abbiamo ricevuto decine e centinaia di
mail contrarie che ci accusavano che
erano contrà riale nostra nostro punto
di vista e vi faccio vedere alcuni di
questi mail erano piacevoli da leggere
perché erano praticamente pellicole come
la seguente in cui questa persona
diceva che 4 grammi di xx al giorno
aveva ottenuto san fratello e su lui
sono o cronica chronic fuga invece no
comment
prima neanche si curava e l'invenzione
dei funghi e dei piedi andiamo più
martinelli che ci ha uniti si fidava
fantastica pelli miracolosa amari mail
era un occhio innamorate la seguente
naturalmente dice che cura anche
malattie degenerative come l'alzheimer
ma voglio attirare la sua attenzione
sulla fase
levin e iniziare da giallo in questa
fase la loro investimenti cioè che deva
preponderante il report il test senza
melfi l'opinione degli spin minori che
lotti italiano dice la grande
maggioranza delle indicazioni
scientifiche è assolutamente contraria
alla vostra posizione
voi siete in netta minoranza science i
demografi processo subito nel processo
educante un fatto è sentito non diventa
verità so perché maggioranza delle
persone di procrea
l'unico delle città e la qualità e
visibilità dei dati sperimentali
quindi anche se noi siamo gli unici a
dire che se non da nessun effetto
i nostri armi sperimentali sono
e al i risvolti quindi amici siamo i
soli a dire una cosa che siamo nella
corretto per la decisione di fare un
altro esempio un esempio molto dell'aics
un esempio storico con di pietro
qualche centinaio d'anni all'epoca di
galileo galilei e facciamo un
democraticissimo referendum maggio
deciderà popolo se la lettera dell
informazione
quest'oggi in parlando a terra alle di
manica linea secondo voi dove serve film
alla croce ci sarebbe stato un bel
uscito tutti avrebbero tranne uno
avrebbe letto e sori una terra ma rulli
barbie le università adesso abbiamo e
sono state è stata la qualità di vita
dei dati a sperimentare sul movimento
dei pianeti generali e galileo che
chiaramente all'epoca non è riuscito a
modificare l'opinione pubblica e ha
rischiato la vita quel desiderio
all'epoca la chiesa utilizzava i testi
biblici per guidare
camminare dell'opinione pubblica
e i testi 15 non sono dei cibi possono
testare i laboratori oggi anche se ha
perso il suo potere temporale ma ci sono
altre lobby altre ideologie politiche o
culturali che utilizzano so che gli
scienziati chiamo se la scienza e
coscienza senza che non è più possibile
sperimentalmente che tentano uno di
cicale opinione pubblica e io credo che
l'unica differenza tra scienza e
coscienza è l'approccio al progetto
democratico senza al contrario la
scienza cerca il consenso democratico ma
non nega le tre scienziati ma
regionalmente del i [ __ ] pubblicate
per modificare le leggi e per avere
delle cadute principalmente per il loro
personale interesse a gomito ci sono
molti cielo scientifici che vengono
discussi in giro per il mondo
gli onesti cioè di modificabili effetto
serra gip bravissimo e
[Applauso]
esagerazione ma che mi chiamò a casa
nostra ci sono state due istituzioni se
lo scientifiche degli ultimi decenni
diciamo che per un cercatore che lavora
all'estero italiano che lavora adesso
hanno fatto vergognare dell'impatto
dello stesso è stato pjanic italia la
consistenza della scientifica hanno
avuto risonanza internazionale quindi se
ne è parlato molto all'estero
parlo del metodo di bella e stalin
in tutti e due i casi di bella finiani
fine degli anni novanta si è cercato di
notizie che mai passato scendano
licenziabili tenuto mai senza
dichiararlo apertamente la loro
negatività su un metodo di pelle si è
cercato di modificare umidi pubblica per
ridurre lo stato a sovvenzionare una
ricerca è pesata parla spendendo milioni
di euro che è la zuppa derivativi poi
sempre paese cosa questa esperienza ha
permesso ai politici attuali bloccare il
protocollo stamina che mi posso dire è a
bada sull'acqua sull'acqua festa però
che a testimoniarlo tecar nei posti due
anni era quasi riuscito a modificare
l'opinione pubblica italiana ea ea quasi
investire versi non c ero un protocollo
e non è basato su nessuna evidenza
scientifica per cui voglio concludere
dicendo non avete paura di scienziati
gli scienziati da me la forma mentis
dello scienziato pallone obiettiva
nostro obiettivo
il mito scientifico l'analisi oggettiva
di tali da loro felicità più visibilità
sperimentale sono principi che
dovrebbero essere applicati non solo nei
laboratori di ricerca ma rispetto della
vita pubblica
e mentre la scienza non è democratica
per democrazia
il bene comune sono garantiti dalla
scelta
[Applauso]
[Musica]